Canada Ursula thank you so much for
being here no matter where we are NATO
meetings Canada EU Summit Brussels G7
leaderships I've always been able to
count on your insights your friendship
and your steadfast values
just ahead of international women's day
tomorrow I'm struck by the fact that
we're here not only with the president
of the European Union but also with our
Deputy Prime Minister our minister of
defense and our Minister of Foreign
Affairs who all happen to be strong
women leaders that is always a pleasure
to see
every day their expertise and dedication
makes the future brighter for people on
both sides of the Atlantic
is
we're here at Canadian Forces base
Kingston to meet and thank the women and
men supporting operations in Europe this
includes Personnel involved in training
Ukrainian Security Forces Canadians in
uniform who've been deployed in Poland
to support Ukrainian refugees and in
Latvia to support NATO
there can be no doubt just as the
resolve of our brave women and men in
uniform is unwavering so too is the bond
between Canada and Europe
already Canada has provided Military
Support to Ukraine and put in place
sanctions and punitive economic measures
against the Russian regime
together president vanlian of underlying
and I also co-hosted an international
pledging event for ukrainians who've
been forced from their homes many of
whom have become refugees
for as long as it takes we will stand
shoulder to shoulder together with our
European partners for Ukraine
today I can announce that we are
extending our engineering training as
part of operation unifier until at least
the fall and deploying CAF medical
trainers to help Ukrainian forces with
combat medical skills
we're also investing three million
dollars for demining in Ukraine and
working with the EU to deliver energy
equipment to Ukraine for their power
grid
foreign
applications
today the president and I also talked
about another shared priority growing
strong and resilient economies and
creating jobs on both sides of the
Atlantic
for over six years now Sita has helped
our businesses work together to create
growth and opportunities later this
afternoon we'll be visiting a Canadian
company that recycles Lithium-ion
batteries for clean tech like electric
vehicles
licycle is not only creating jobs and
building up our critical mineral Supply
in Canada
they're opening plants in Europe too so
they can do the same there
whether it's ways that Canada is leading
or ways the EU is leading or ways in
which we're leading together this
partnership means good jobs for our
workers and resources that the world
needs So today we're strengthening this
partnership even further
visited
is
[Music]
the new Canada EU enhanced action plan
on hydrogen will mobilize investment
support businesses share expertise and
get clean Canadian hydrogen to Europe
fundamentally it's about good
middle-class jobs economic growth and
clean energy
this is on top of work together on
protecting nature and fighting climate
change to deliver a strong future for
our kids and grandkids
there is so much that Canada and Europe
share a commitment to the people of
Ukraine to defending democracy and
international law and to protecting
human rights shared values like gender
equality and a commitment to Growing the
middle class and making sure people have
good careers they can be proud of and
build their families and communities
around
and a belief that we can and will build
a strong healthy future for generations
to come
to Canada is
thank you very much prime minister Dear
Justin I've been very much looking
forward to this visit
indeed Canada is one of the European
Union's most trusted partners
we share the same vision of the world
the same democratic values
we believe in the power of cooperation
solidarity and multilateralism
we are not only Partners we are true
friends
and it is as close friends that we work
together through this last year that we
coordinated our support for example to
the brave people of Ukraine United in a
common purpose
I know the deep and historical ties That
You Canada have with our neighbor
Ukraine
I was deeply impressed when in April
last year many Canadian men and women
went from here in Kingston
from Edmonton or from other Canadian
bases all the way to Poland
they went to Europe to help the
Ukrainian people who had to flee
Russia's bump
I'm also deeply impressed by the
hospitality you immediately gave to
Ukrainian refugees here in Canada
thousands of them
just as we did in the European Union we
welcome sheltered and producted 4
million refugees from Ukraine
we have also strongly aligned our
successive packages of sanctions against
Russia together with our G7 partners
sanctions are biting deep and hard from
going after Putin's cronies and
propagandists
to draining the resources he needs to
wage his warp for example the very
successful oil price caps that we have
agreed on together
we will keep supporting Ukraine in these
dark times until Ukraine prevails
we're both stepping up our support to
Ukraine including our military support
because ukrainians have all the
necessary grit and spirit but what they
need is weapons
the European Union has already delivered
12 billion euros worth of military
equipment so far
in parallel we will continue training
Ukrainian soldiers like you are doing so
but you have been doing since 2015
already
and therefore here too our coordination
with the Canadian Mission and the EU
military assistant mission in Ukraine
and for Ukraine is excellent
our goal is on the European side to
train 30 000 troops by the end of the
year
in addition addition Dear Justin I very
much welcome your intention to deliver
generators to Ukraine very much needed
in these times where people put in a
strategically destroying the energy
infrastructure and civil infrastructure
in Ukraine and I also welcome that
you're ready to join forces with us to
support the demining in Ukraine
these are a few examples but it's all
exemplary for the very strong alignment
we have between Canada and the European
Union
so of course it's not only for the
present
challenge that we are standing shoulder
by shoulder but also for the mid and
long term we will help Ukraine together
to rebuild its beautiful country with
the support that we gathered through our
G7 donors platform
a second issue we discussed today is
critical raw materials
they are the lifeblood of the clean
economy
we need them to reach our ambitious
decarbonization objectives
this is why of course the European
Union's focus is very strong on the
resilience of our supply chains
but we see today that for example China
produces 98 of Europe's supplies of rare
earth
and Europe needs to de-risk this
dependency
and this of course is immediately
the reason why Europe seeks to work
together with trusted Partners when
trusted Partners is first and foremost
Canada
the only country actually in the
northern hemisphere with all the raw
materials needed to produce Lithium-ion
batteries
you have a vast experience on mining and
processing
and we know and that is important in
combination we know the importance that
you attach to labor rights
to Environmental Protection and to the
respect for local communities
we have started a partnership on
critical raw materials in 2021
it is already bearing fruit now it's
time to take it to the next level
let's build on the excellent cooperation
between us and our companies
for example the Swedish North Vault
partnering with Vail Canada
to ramp up supplies of low carbon nickel
used to manufacture electric vehicles
another typical example is the Belgian
Yumi Corps that is planning to build a
battery materials production plant right
here in Ontario
so we will step up work with our
respective Industries there is already a
whole pipeline of very promising
projects an exploration Mining and
processing
we will support our businesses in
matchmaking we will identify good
investment opportunities and we will
also boost and accelerate the joint
research that we are doing
finally last but certainly not least
we discussed our cooperation on climate
change
we are in a very strong position to lead
the way globally
and together we can rally the
International Community behind Net Zero
by 2050
you mentioned the opportunity to have a
memorandum of understanding on hydrogen
another key to the successful transition
is carbon pricing
so I'm very happy to work for the
European Union to join your Global
carbon pricing challenge
and finally we want to create as an
overarching topic as an umbrella
basically a green alliance between the
European Union and Canada
it's to create good and well-paying jobs
to promote growth to boost our energy
and climate cooperation
across the board and yes one shining
example for that how well once in place
an agreement works is Sita I've just
looked up the latest figure so the
increase of trade between us is by now
in 2022 66 percent so quite a step
forward
opportunity
foreign
Elizabeth
insurance
self
no democracy The Americans
utilities
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]
I think we have to keep in mind two
clear objectives when it comes to
foreign interference particularly these
days Chinese interference into our
democracy the first one is to make sure
that the tools the processes the bodies
we have within our government and our
democracy
are able to do everything necessary to
protect our democracy to protect our
institutions and our elections from
foreign interference
the second goal related but distinct is
to make sure that Canadians have
confidence that all those tools are
being used and that we are
continuing to see free Fair protected
elections despite attempts by Foreign
governments to interfere
as we move forward
on those two goals of making sure we
have the proper tools and giving
confidence to Canadians
we will of course be open to suggestions
that the various parties put forward for
names for this independent special
rapporteur and we will ensure that
whoever is chosen is someone who both
has the capacity to ensure that we're
doing all the right things to fight
interference
and has the capacity to give all
Canadians confidence in the openness
transparency and rigor of that process
foreign
so I see that Canada is doing much more
than its fair share already compared to
others and is going Way Beyond what is
uh necessary so I want to thank Canada
for that indeed it's not only the
military equipment I know the Intensive
work on doing work with the defense
industry to scale up ammunition for
example standardized ammunition in
Canada the 155 millimeter ammunition
badly needed in Ukraine I'm very
grateful that you're working on that
because every day counts right now but
we know also that Canada from the very
beginning on has been a staunch
supporter what the budget support is
concerned I mentioned the support for
the Ukrainian refugees the training of
Ukrainian forces that Canada started way
earlier than other countries in 2015 the
operation unifier is bearing has beared
has had its uh success immediately at
the beginning of the Russian invasion in
Ukraine because the Ukrainian troops
were much better trained than it was in
2014 the case so it's also thanks to
this support from Canada that Ukraine at
the very beginning of this war was
immediately able to resist this Invasion
so I want to thank you for the support
that goes Way Beyond what is the average
next question hi there my question is
also for the European commissioner
president Europe is trying to move away
from Russian energy but there are
limited options Canada for example
doesn't exactly have the capacity when
it comes to export especially when it
comes to natural gas are you
disappointed in the position that Europe
finds itself right now and is it even
possible for Europe to completely
isolate Russia when it comes to Oil and
Gas
it is an extraordinary Journey that we
have undertaken during the last year
that was a big over dependency at the
beginning of the Russian invasion in
Ukraine of Europe's energy needs an
over-dependency on Russian fossil fuels
we have gotten rid of Russian coal We
have basically gotten rid of Russian oil
and Russia itself cut 80 percent of its
gas supplies we were the biggest
the biggest client of Russia Russia cut
80 percent of its gas supplies in only
eight months this was an enormous
challenge we could see how the gas
prices were skyrocketing because energy
Supply globally was tightening what have
we done we have immediately Diversified
away from Russia to like-minded trusted
partners
most and foremost the United States with
LNG but also Norway with pipeline gas
Canada helped a lot by increasing its
LNG production we do not have the
necessary infrastructure to link Canada
directly with the European Union but the
increased production of LNG here in
Canada helped the global market
to supply enough LNG to those who needed
it for example the European Union second
element we saved energy the Europeans
saved 20 percent of their energy
consumption during the last year the
third element is the most important we
massively invested in renewable energy
because this is not only good for the
climate
but it's also good for our independence
and it creates jobs at home
and here I must say last year for the
very first time we produced more
electricity from wind and solar
than from gas
and overall if you look at the figures
of last year we were even able to reduce
the CO2 emissions by two and a half
percent so it was a very difficult
Journey but in the very end thanks to
our friends and partners we were able to
come out stronger than the we started
last year
thank you very much and my follow-up is
to the Prime Minister on a similar
question today Pierre Paulie have
accused you of helping to fund foreign
dictators by shedding out Canada's
natural oil and gas sorry natural gas
industry given demand from European
leaders why does it appear that there's
a bit of a hesitation on the part of
your government to expand to meet this
growing demand there is no hesitation we
will continue to work very hard to be
there for European Partners at now and
long into the future at Canada continues
to export natural gas and oil to the
world including through Investments that
this government oversaw in the largest
private sector investment in Canada's
history with LNG Canada on the west
coast as that moves forward we continue
to develop Canada's
importance as a source of energy
but we know
that the world is changing and then even
as Europe is facing significant needs
that we're happy to work with them to
respond to and that we're encouraging
our companies to look at
we know that the transformation of our
Energy Mix towards lower carbon and
Renewables is going to be essential
which is why Canada can position itself
to be a supplier a reliable supplier of
energy in a net zero world
and The Innovation and the leadership
that's going on in our energy sector
right now including by extraordinary uh
energy workers in Alberta and
Saskatchewan and Newfoundland who are in
the traditional energy sectors are
leading the charge in decarbonization of
our traditional sources while they're
investing in Innovation and growth in
Renewables we are there to support
trusted Partners as the world is
discovering that Russia and other
authoritarian states are not trusted
Partners upon which to build strong
economic growth for our citizens or for
our our countries that's why Canada is
so pleased to be working so closely with
the European Union and other partners as
we ensure that we're meeting energy
needs now and long into the future as we
approach Net Zero next question
okay
um
uh the the response with the the project
the the resource uh
announced
this is
economics
returning to the issue of foreign
interference and Democratic institutions
which I know is an issue on both sides
of the Atlantic in different contexts
prime minister today the opposition
leader accused you of working against
Canada's interests failing to act
because the liberal party has stood to
benefit how do leaders in Western
democracies that are currently in power
Act without looking like they're just
being defensive in their own
self-interest
I think one of the important things that
citizens in democracies around the world
have understood is how important it is
to support our institutions whether it's
institutions like selections Canada or
an independent judiciary
or an independent expert public service
that continues to do the work of
supporting Canadians and delivering
services for Citizens regardless of the
political party that's in power
the impact and the threat of foreign
interference we've seen in all sorts of
different elections around the world
and it is upon all of us as leaders
to ensure that even as we are
strengthening our capacity as
democracies and as institutions to
respond to that
that we're not falling into the Trap of
actually weakening Canadians confidence
in those institutions uh by leaning in
heavily on partisan accusations
I understand that this is a difficult
and a
very concerning issue for Canadians that
are rightly asking all sorts of
questions which is why
the government has chosen to move
forward on bringing an independent
Special Report who will be charged with
reassuring Canadians even as they
strengthen our ability to respond to
interference
and lean in and highlight on the
excellent work done by the institutions
that we've built up to protect from
foreign interference I will again
highlight that
Mr pauliev has long been opposed to the
idea of a national security and
intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians when he was part of
Stephen Harper's government they were
directly and aggressively
opposed to the idea of swearing in of
get getting
um
high top secret security clearances to
opposition MPS
so that a committee of parliamentarians
with the appropriate clearances from all
parties could lean in deeply and
thoroughly into the actions that our
intelligence Community is taking or not
taking to keep Canadians safe
this was something that the conservative
party long opposed and it's something
that Mr pauliev despite excellent work
done over the past many years by
conservative members on the National
Security and intelligence Committee of
parliamentarians Mr poliov continues
to misrepresent
and attack this important oversight body
that was modeled on what countries
around democracies around the world do
to keep Canadian they keep their
citizens safe and indeed is a committee
that regularly puts out public reports
to Parliament on extremely delicate
issues that they have dug into deeply we
have strong institutions and responsible
leadership
is about supporting those institutions
even as uh one finds points of
disagreement with other political
parties
Madam president am I
am I in your remarks today that Europe
has in effect given up on the idea of
getting LNG directly from Canada in
favor of the other approaches that you
described there where Canadian LNG goes
south and you focus now on Renewables
exports uh if you haven't given up on
the idea
what instead would it take hear from
both of you on that
so what I said is that in the acute
crisis in 2022 the infrastructure was
not in place
um what comes in the future is up to the
business sector to also see the
opportunities and of course there will
be additional LNG infrastructure in the
European Union because we need some LNG
in different areas of the European Union
and this infrastructure is being built
but there's a very clear understanding
common understanding in the European
Union that in the mid and long term
we need the bridge to the Renewables
and we have in the European union agreed
on climate goals we have cast them in
law we have a very clear roadmap how to
get there and this includes for example
the development of hydrogen
Canada is one of the Prime potential
partner for hydrogen and this is the
reason why we are working on a
memorandum of understanding for hydrogen
because we cannot only solve the crisis
right now what we did successfully in
the last 12 months but we also have to
pave the path to the Future and our
future will be Renewables there will be
a base load certainly nuclear or gas but
the vast majority of energy will be
Renewables and hydrogen the European
Union is planning on producing on its
own 10 million tons of hydrogen by 2030
but also importing 10 million tons of
hydrogen by 2030. so and this is
something where this is a lot what we
need where we really need to work with
trusted partner and start now the
corporation
and if I could just add let's be very
clear the 40 billion dollar
LNG Canada project on the west coast to
export LNG and displace coal in Asia
it was not a government project
it was a Consortium led by shell of
international companies that saw a
business case in doing exactly that and
we fully supported them in their ability
to do that but it was a commercial
project similarly there are companies
looking into the viability and the value
of exporting LNG off the east coast and
they are making their decisions on
Market expectations and Commercial
principles we as a government will of
course be there to support and
facilitate it if there's an company
interested invested but it's not a
government project that's going to do
that it's private companies just like
it's private companies in in Germany and
in Europe that are receiving and putting
orders for LNG from Canada
good afternoon prime minister Taria
Israel with global news when it comes to
the investigation into election
interference you said you want it to be
non-partisan but when election
interference reports initially surfaced
you suggested it was racist to raise
these concerns but several Chinese
Canadian leaders have said that was
reductive and that you ignored their
warnings about interference so do you
have anything to say to Chinese
Canadians who may feel ignored and do
you take responsibility for politicizing
this issue on the contrary I have heard
regularly from Chinese Canadians who are
pointing out that the first targets of
foreign interference from China
are always Chinese Canadians
that it is diaspora communities
themselves that far from being as some
have chosen to suggest perpetrators of
foreign interference are actually
targets of foreign interference and I
think it's extremely important for us to
understand that standing up for all
Canadians includes standing up
for Canadians who can trace their roots
to different countries around the world
whether it's China or Iran or Russia who
are themselves the primary targets of
interference I think that's something
that often gets overlooked in the
discussions around foreign interference
but
I'm sure can we get a little bit more
specific on the Mandate is it to
investigate allegations of meddling or
whether your government knew about these
allegations and did not act as we said a
number of times the special rapporteur
will be there to ensure that Canada has
all the mechanisms and tools necessary
and is making best use of them to
counter foreign interference and to
reassure Canadians that we are doing
exactly that
this is a key to the work that the
special rapporteur will do in an
independent and rigorous way
but part of one of the things we learned
from commissioner roulo's response
around the the public order emergency
commission was working with the special
rapporteur to establish the right terms
of reference and mandate for them to
achieve those two goals of making sure
we have the right systems and reassuring
Canadians that everything necessary to
be done has been and will be done
involving them is really important thank
you that will conclude today's press
conference
let's go
[Music]